joe biden discussing the
potential illegitimacy of the election
is not
the dumbest most catastrophic thing that
he said in recent days that would
probably be joe biden's invitation
practically speaking invitation to the
russians to invade ukraine
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having a fight about
what to do and not do etc but if they
actually do what they're capable of
doing with the force amassed on the
border it is going to be a disaster for
russia if they further engrade you i
wanted to follow up briefly on a
question asked by bloomberg you said
that russia would be held accountable if
it invades and it depends on what it
does are you saying that a minor
incursion by russia into ukrainian
territory would not lead to the
sanctions that you have threatened or
are you effectively giving putin
permission to make a small incursion
into the country
good question
um
that's how it did sound like didn't it
yeah
when i when i said that we wouldn't do
anything if russia only invades part of
ukraine i guess it sounded like i'd i
said that that russia could invade part
of ukraine
yeah i guess
anyway moving on next question
it sounded like that because that's
that's exactly what you said and he
doesn't he doesn't even try to correct
it this is probably
the worst case scenario
because
here
joe biden is is not
standing firm with ukraine and saying do
not invade russia they're going to be
serious consequences if you invade
ukraine
and he he's not even rolling over and
saying okay just come ukraine is yours
now i'm just going to give you ukraine
he's he's in this awful middle ground
where he's saying okay russia
you can you can roll those tanks in and
you can take some small part of ukraine
and you can kill some people and you can
shoot some bullets but not too many
not too much
or
else uh
uh or else what
i never want to hear about russian
collusion again
it was always so crazy that the
democrats accused republicans of
colluding with the russians after
democrats spent a full century colluding
with the russians from the communist
revolution in russia up until today the
left has been colluding with the
russians
they wanted warmer relationships with
the russians they opposed attempts to
stop russian expansion they opposed uh
ronald reagan's policy in the cold war
for instance to out-spend the russians
to destroy the soviet union ronald
reagan was asked what's what's your
strategy on the cold war he said it's a
simple strategy we win and they lose the
left lost their minds over that hillary
clinton when she was secretary of state
begged for a russian reset she wanted
warmer relations with russia
i think that there are good arguments
for
warming up relations with russia to play
off of china for instance i don't think
that's the left's game because i think
the left is sucking up to china even
more than they are to russia
but the idea that republicans are
somehow softer on russia than the
democrats is
absurd
and here we have the clearest example of
that joe biden inviting russia to invade
what is today
an independent nation ukraine
more proof that the left projects and
it's a really important lesson because
when you're in the moment of of getting
some accusation from the left your your
instinct is to defend your instinct is
to take it seriously your instinct is to
try to reason your way out of it
i don't think you have to do that when
the left comes out and calls you a
racist probably the clearest example you
don't need to defend yourself you don't
need to explain to them why you're not a
racist
the democrat party is
deeply deeply racist
it views politics through the lens of
race much much more so than republicans
do the democrats are advocating policies
which create racial hierarchies and
reward some races and punish other races
you don't need to take it seriously when
they call you then just laugh at them
maybe
give them a couple of words that aren't
happy birthday and go on your merry way
certainly the same thing is true with
when they tell you that
the republicans are colluding with
russia you don't need to you don't need
to explain how you're not really
colluding with russia and actually trump
was misunderstood when he said this or
that just laugh at them
they're just projecting they've been
colluding with russia for a century
kamikoto makes great traditional
japanese steel kitchen knives using the
traditional techniques from japan kami
koto taps into more than 800 years of
traditional techniques from honshu japan
they only use steel sourced from mills
in japan each blade is crafted using
techniques that have been honed and
perfected for centuries for generations
it makes a really great gift i love
these knives they look beautiful they're
presented in this lovely
beautiful ash wood box they're they're
great for
chopping up things in the kitchen
they're great for preparing dinner
they're great for scaring your
colleagues at the daily wire when you
get your set of kamikoto knives as well
well they've got a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional 50 bucks off any
purchase you make with the discount code
knowles click the link below or go to
kamikodo.com
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s use promo code
knowles kenner wles to save an extra 50
bucks today treat yourself in in the
kitchen to these really terrific knives
wonderful great tradition you will thank
me later i'm so glad that you liked that
clip i liked it as well if you want to
get more of those videos
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show boom
subscribe leave a five star review if
you wouldn't mind we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you